Wolffe the Planet of the Apes is
probably the most evolved performance
capture that is seen today but when I
think back to Lord of the Rings and
where it all started there's been such a
huge journey in terms of the evolution
of the technology the hardware the
cameras the software everything that
goes into transforming and actors
performance into an avatar character
[Music]
motion capture came out the medical
industry but then it was used in early
video games so that would be by using a
suit with retro reflective markers
placed at joints in the body the
information which is then piped into the
computer that provides then an
electronic skeleton which is then added
to an animated rig so the process of
shooting on all the Rings was to go on
set and work with the other actors on
location then we'd have to do a second
pass with the camera I would stand off
to the side and then they would react to
the ball on a stick and they would then
capture their performances then I would
go back to a motion capture studio where
I'd climb into the motion capture suit
they would play back the scenes that
I've been working and I would be able to
see on the screen in real time a
representation of Gollum so if I lifted
up my right hand columns all right and
if I twisted my body it would totally
move in sync with my movements it was in
effect being like a puppeteer and
marionette at the same time the next
film that I worked on was King Kong the
difference this time around was that it
made the transition from motion capture
to performance capture because I was
wearing a hundred and thirty two retro
reflective markers on my face which were
assigned to muscle groups that would
then directly drive the digital mask of
King Kong all of which were picked up by
a bank of cameras only a hundred and
eighty degree field so I couldn't turn
my back the basis of the character
design the actor sees from a very early
point so you see I knew that his facial
design was going to accentuate some of
my own facial structure so this is where
we get the transition
to what we call performance capture it's
capturing audio facial and body all at
the same time the task in
post-production is always going to be
that ability to take the actors
performance and actually be interpolated
performance whilst retaining it but also
putting on the physiognomy of a 1/8 so
it's almost like looking at a costume
that you're going to put on and choose
as an actor and you find a relationship
between yourself in the Avatar then the
next significant change was tinting and
[Music]
this was when we started to introduce
head mounted cameras so this allowed the
actor to be shot in 360 degrees it meant
that you're untethered and therefore can
move about and play your part very
naturally the next significant change
was taking everything out of a motion
capture studio and being able to shoot
on location and this happened with the
Rise of the Planet of the Apes so this
was the first time that we had this real
synergy and ability to create the scene
once in camera both using traditional
film cameras but also the motion capture
cameras and boom mounted cameras for
facial expressions now this is still
interiors this is the first for instance
in Rise for the Planet of the Apes it
was the house that Caesar was brought up
in and they also built a section of San
Francisco bridge for the unactive end
sequence where there were upwards of I
think 200 motion capture cameras placed
all along a stretch of purpose-built set
the next jump forward was then taking
and making all these suits much more
robust and by going outside we needed to
have a slightly different approach to
the markers they were no longer
retro-reflective but actually sent out
an infrared pulse so that meant that we
could shoot outdoors in bright light
dawn took it a stage further by taking
it into much more shall we say
challenging environments such as the
Vancouver rain forests and when we're
shooting in New Orleans we were 100%
humidity and the technology had to stand
up to all of that and that again was
taken to a further extreme in war for
the Planet of the Apes when we were
shooting in - conditions and I
shoots up to our wasting snow all of
this technology had been built to the
point where it was incredibly robust now
as well as rendering and the texturing
the fur the eyes the hair water the
ability to have snow or rain on for all
of this technology had been evolving so
that the simulations were all becoming
much more photo real so many people
think studying the role for Caesar for
instance is purely about copying eight
movements and to put everybody straight
on that that is really sort of room 101
that's where you begin after a while you
realize that it's not just about
mimicking behavior this is about
creating a character so there are all
these psychological and emotional
journeys that one has to import into the
character so it's not just about the
physical build of the character but the
whole internalization and that's why the
misconception that performance capture
acting is a sort of genre or type of
acting is completely wrong it's no
different to any process that you go
through to create a role with your
onstage in front of a screen in the more
conventional sense the actors
performance is the actors performance
[Music]